[Música]
vocês sabem a diferença entre
desconstruir e destruir destruir segundo
o dicionário houaiss significa que vai
estar a destroçar demolir e matar
enquanto desconstruir significa desfazer
já estava construída e construindo algo
novo no lugar frequentemente fugir da
tradição e é mais ou menos um ano atrás
eu descobri a importância e saber se a
diferença estava no facebook
e eu vi um debate sobre a proteção
cultural porque é uma cantora de usar
tranças no rio e eu fui lá da opinião
porque eu sou negro me interessa muito
pelo assunto e flamengo testando os
comentários mas o texto não se perdeu na
montanha de xingamentos e frases de
efeito e - da grade do facebook
e aí é eu resolvi fazer o meu texto e em
vídeo neste vídeo é explicável aqui pra
mim o problema da proteção cultural
não era uma garota branca usando
turbante ou tranças são empresas que
branqueiam comportamento de melhorias
para tentar tornar eles mais comerciais
vendáveis gerando assim um problema
enorme de falta de representatividade e
preconceito e eu fui colocar esse vídeo
no meu perfil pessoal no facebook
e esse vídeo em dois dias tinha 4
milhões de views e assim em quatro
milhões de views é muito 4 milhões de
views é 2% da população brasileira é
mais do que toda a população do uruguai
e assim eu acabei vendo nisso uma
oportunidade uma plataforma para poder
falar de vários temas da minha vida né
temas sociais temas lgbt temas raciais e
eu criei um blog chamado espaço do blog
e há mais ou menos um ano eu tenho esse
canal que hoje em dia já tem mais de 70
milhões de views e tal mas naquela época
aqueles 4 milhões me assustaram muito e
aí o art
lamento por não entender o que tinha
acontecido e aí eu via todo mundo
falando que eu era didático né
eu fiquei aqui gente já que vem essa
demanda por didatismo internet e
acontece a internet hoje é uma
ferramenta incrível para poder lutar
pelos nossos direitos para poder lutar
por igualdade com representatividade
para poder principalmente denunciar
grupos que intencionalmente oprimem
grupos que sabem de seus privilégios
escolhem ser machistas racistas
homofóbicos e assim é importante que
estes três grupos antes que ele não
registrou só que existem momentos para
ser mal com ex momentos para ser martin
luther king
existem momentos onde a solução também
não ser em momentos onde a solução está
na didática e é muito difícil entender
isso e aceitar isso é muito difícil você
ouve uma pessoa falando uma barbaridade
uma coisa que te fere e você tem empatia
e você sem violência pegar na mão dela
explicou que ela tá errado
principalmente no ambiente game ficado
das redes sociais um professor e um dia
me mostrou como as redes sociais são uma
espécie de game um jogo onde você já o
conteúdo à espera para ver qual vai ser
sua pontuação de likes comentários e
compartilhamentos e todo mundo aqui é
viciado nesse jogo fica checando toda
hora
sua pontuação e aí essa lógica de game
ela também altera as conversas as
disputa os diálogos eles viram disputas
e interlocutor inimigo e como no jogo
você não quer levar o inimigo pessoal
você quer destruir ele se quer humilhar
você quer expor
você quer que ele desative o perfil pra
sentir que você venceu a discussão que
você me irritou e assim um amigo meu que
também o tubo chamado gabriel estrela um
gm mostrou como esse termo militou
militar é um termo bélico é um tema
associado à instituição ea gente não
está lidando com o inimigo está lidando
com uma pessoa
uma pessoa que tem que se desfazer de
todos esses conceitos opressores e
retrógradas através do aprendizado
mas a gente freqüentemente não usa nossa
voz para gerar aprendizado
a gente usa nossas vozes para nosso
próprio ego
a gente vê um comentário que a gente
discorda a gente vê uma publicação ea
gente acha uma barbaridade e nós a
primeira reação é colocar uma carinha
nervosa e lá e fazer um comentário
xingando compartilhar indignado pra
sentir que a gente é bom para sentir que
a gente fez nossa parte por um mundo
melhor
e enfim pra sentir que a gente lutou
contra o inimigo
só que não é assim que as coisas
funcionam porque depois que colocou sua
carinha nervosa a pessoa que faça coisa
errada
ela não mudou de idéia ela não aprendeu
nada e assim eu acho que isso mostra que
a gente tem um grande problema de
diagnóstico porque a gente acha que o
problema são os opressores e não as
idéias que faz as pessoas serem
professoras é tem uma teoria de
filosofia que é muito básica é pura
teoria da tábua rasa que fala que todos
nós vemos para esse mundo bebezinhos
lindos fofos sem saber nada ea gente
aprendeu das escolas da sede das
instituições da sociedade um monte de
porcaria que fez a gente fazer os erros
que a gente faz
da mesma forma que as pessoas aprendem
as idéias
elas podem aprender eu acho que sim
todos nós estamos aqui juntos passando
por um processo de desconstrução
todos nós estamos evoluindo tem muita
gente hoje que é contra a homofobia que
há cinco anos atrás estava indo de perda
de gordura
tem muita gente hoje que fala que é
contra a homofobia mas que no fundo têm
medo que o filho seja gay e assim meu
pai por exemplo e nunca lidou muito bem
com minha sexualidade
meu pai é um homem negro da bahia
ele é motorista de ônibus e assim ele
não me criou que me criei a minha volta
e você terá aqui e assim a gente nunca
teve muito contato mas eu lembro quando
eu tinha 16 anos e estava com meus
colegas no colégio e aí a gente tira uma
foto de zoeira um colega botou a língua
no céu
ele e eu postei no orkut e aí meu pai
viu a foto e ele ficou muito indignado
ele saiu da casa dele e ver foi até a
casa da minha avó me perguntar se o
filho dele tinha virado e aí
naquele momento eu fiquei muito irritado
e eu escolhi destruir e resolvi jogar
tudo na cara dele falar que ele não
tinha moral nenhuma para poder falar
nada daquilo que era um pai ausente que
ele não estava lá para me ensinar nada
mas queria falar no programa x e foi
horrível porque assim ele saiu de lá mal
eu fiquei mal ele não mudou de idéia
isso não resolveu nada e assim o tempo
passou e é mais ou menos dois anos atrás
eram os partidos mais parecido com esse
aqui só que ainda não tinha saído do
armário e aí eu fui lá visitar meu pai
minhas tatuagens e aí tudo bem e mostrar
meu pai nem olhou na minha cara
já tinha havido boatos e ele nem olhava
pra mim e eu fiquei pensando será que eu
vou fazer com meu braço incomodava tanto
ele imagina que fazer com este meu corpo
e aí naquele momento resolvi falar com
meu pai
pai eu sou gay
só que naquele momento eu decidi
construir e e falei 'pai eu sempre um
filho muito responsável e dedicado
eu sempre nunca de trabalho com minha
avó e assim você mesmo ser um pai
ausente você sempre foi um exemplo
também porque você sempre foi um cara
muito trabalhador muito honestos e nunca
fez nada errado eu sempre te levar pra
minha vida entendeu e assim eu tinha
muito e cheguei não muda nada disso
e aí meu pai ele
[Aplausos]
e aí meu pai chorou
eu chorei e ri se abraçou e ele falou
que me amava mas lamentavelmente china e
eu pude falar pra ele pela primeira vez
que não tinha que lamentar que eu tenho
orgulho de ser quem era e assim hoje eu
não sei se meu pai eu já sei que minha
sexualidade mas pela primeira vez na
vida eu pude ter uma oportunidade para
falar disso com ele pude criar uma ponte
eu pude ter uma porta aberta e assim
tudo porque eu escolhi desconstruir ao
invés de extrair tudo que eu tentei a
comunicação não violenta
tudo porque eu acredito que pessoas com
idéias ruins podem mudar de idéia e esse
é o convite que faça todos vocês se
vocês verem uma pessoa que tem uma
opinião muito contrário vocês vocês
discordam tentem conversar tentar
empatia tentem pegar pela mão explicar o
que você pensa porque assim melhor do
que pisar na pessoa trazendo o seu lado
e assim tão importante quanto
desconstruir é ouvir porque só assim a
gente também se livra dos nossos
próprios preconceitos entranhados e
transforma disputas em diálogos
afinal não é com xingamento atração que
a gente consegue dialogar com um
obrigado
[Aplausos]